all right welcome to another edition of
a beginner breakdown i am your host Mike
hunter a chess club hosted a big
tournament over the weekend the Missouri
class championship and the Missouri
novice Championship the Missouri novice
Championship head over 50 players and so
are we going over some of the games so
this game will be going over is it it's
quick one it's board one on one of the
divisions okay one of the classes so at
the end of the game let's see if what
class they were in under 1,200 the
novice class be master all right so so
here it is board one for a hundred fifty
dollars are actually three hundred
dollars and a plaque okay so white
starts out with this Queen pawn the
player playing black knight of six so so
this is a good setup for white he's got
his pawns connected and so now he brings
his other night out this is not good to
try to challenge the center with just
these nights you need some some puns to
help him out alright so white brings out
his Knight to f3 e6 is played targeting
be4 so Knight to c3 so now it gets the
pin okay so what is the best move for
white here it's a so moved at a been
fine gold really enjoys as well Joe you
know Queen see to Queens to do it does a
lot it protects the night and stops this
night from coming in to be four so plays
the move h 6 pi wasn't really necessary
in this position so white grabs the
center with e for excellent so it plays
the move d6 and now it's time for white
to attack okay so you got all these
three puns out here and you can do a lot
of damage with them so who is the only
player protecting this Bishop the night
right so if we could try to get that
night out of there maybe so maybe we can
get a tactic going it's not forcing but
it's it's good so this is along the
lines of hope chests as you're hoping
you know he'll make a bad move but this
is also a good move that keeps the
attack going so it's a mixture of good
moves and hope chests so if we could get
this night out of here maybe something
good can happen yeah d5 attacks the
night so now so now if he moves the
night as we'll see it's not going to be
very pleasant for for the player playing
black but black has an easy move that
doesn't lose a piece here Bishop takes
Knight check because it's a forcing move
and then we'll have to uh no let me to
take back with the Queen because even if
it takes our epon we can we can snag
this Jeep on and then potentially the
night okay alright so but in the game of
course he retreats to e7 here and
disaster is going to strike for black so
basically look for your checks and your
captures undefended pieces in your
territory and it's pretty easy to come
to the conclusion of what this tactic is
Joe's got it Queen a Ford check okay
attack the undefended piece double
attack and game over okay he decides he
doesn't want to play on you know down a
piece for you know the time control is
game in two hours so he doesn't want to
sit there for three hours and he just
wants to go so that was bored one
anybody have any guesses what the vision
that was yeah is a trick question good
cuz the white played pretty well yeah
that was the Tommy Julian game no no
this was the Class B so white got three
hundred dollars in a plaque in record
time okay so now we'll show you a game
that maybe not as good but it does last
longer here's a game from the class c
championship the names are messed up
here Eric Hoffner Eric got a got a
lesson saturday night from me after the
tournament so so he was really jazzed
and really pumped to to win here so
let's check out how he does in this game
against Wilson alright so Wilson starts
out efore will flip the board Eric is
our hero plain black so he plays the
Sicilian he plays this d6 variation
which which is pretty good for beginners
to play because if they ever try to get
in 'if I've here okay we'll just take it
okay so we don't have to worry about our
night getting attacked by e5 so so it's
pretty good and we don't really have to
worry about this check i mean it doesn't
really do much alright so so why play is
the typical d-force okay
weeks Knight takes we want to stay away
from moves like 'if I've here because it
would create a hole in a this.d five
square and all it does is attack the
night and makes this pun really really
bad on on d6 so he plays Knight up six
attacks the pawn he protects and now a
g6 is played we got adjourn in the house
excellent and so Bishop c4 so ran if you
play g6 there's no reason to ever wait
just play Bishop g7 but unfortunately he
doesn't hear first he plays a six so f3
solidifies the pawn structure so now be
five Bishop back and now Bishop the b7
you see how with Erics last couple moves
you play g6 which is nice okay and then
he was two away from getting castle
Bishop g7 and castle but instead he kind
of diverted his uh his thought process
so now he's got dis guy Ian settled but
he's still two away from castling
unfortunately white doesn't have a good
way to break through here on f7 or
anything here so Bishop e3 night up so
Queen to d2 okay so so the Queen and
Bishop are in a battery here so
obviously they want to go to h6 here
okay so so black could just play Bishop
g7 here Bishop h6 castle but that could
get dangerous after h4 if they ever let
me play it okay so he decide I don't
want to get attacked on the King side so
he decides to play h5 here instead of
Bishop g7 okay so Rick d1 night attacks
the bishop
so he doesn't want double pawns even
though I guess Knight takes Knight and
the night could take but anyway so he's
like I'm going to challenge the bishop
so he captures it night captures and he
brings his rook up okay so see three and
so now he's getting his pawn up here age
three so so now the moment of truth why
do you think Eric kept pushing this pawn
obviously at first it was the stop
Bishop h6 but what do you think the
point of h4 is mario here you know this
answer yes you do it get the rook to h5
okay excellent and of course this is the
Class C division okay guys so don't be
afraid to play anybody if their rating
says 1500 it's like they're still going
to be playing like amateurs because
anybody not ranked two thousand is an
amateur alright so night attacks the
rook and now goes back so now so now
with that with that maneuver black can
no longer castle period in this game
he's got no place to go so Bishop
attacks the pawn but but notice even
though blacks king is in the center he
does have a lot of pieces guarding it so
it's very difficult for white to
actually generate an attack on this king
he should probably get castled himself
and start like pushing this pawn and
breaking through alright so Queen a five
attacks the pawn and so he protects with
a be four so it works back to h5 attacks
the bishop here night attacks the Queen
and so the Queen goes back a bishop back
to e3 and night here all right hello sir
welcome to the class
no problem no problem so now white makes
a mistake here he puts his night where
it can get captured so he gladly
captures it and now if you're not really
paying attention here you have to take
back with well if you take back with the
Queen that's that's trouble to write
write it loses the Queen the night takes
check but now you take back with the
pawn and now we have a tactic it's a to
move combination it involves just like
the last game a double attack where the
Queen was attacking the king and the
bishop now we just find a find a way to
attack two things at once possibly with
a fork and will be a will be in business
so what can we attack here
you see anything yet adjourn okay night
does what okay okay we're actually
attacking not just the Queen in the pond
we're actually attacking the Queen and
the bishop ok so now notice when it
plays Queen to e2 what is all on this
line here the white king the Queen and
the bishop so now we take it and if the
Queen would take back what move would we
slam on the board here rookie five
excellent so so there was no real excuse
for white never to get castled in this
position because I mean this this H
plane was going nowhere so when you keep
the King in the center especially when
you don't have any pawns in front of you
disaster can strike pretty easy so it
looked like an innocent exchange here
when he put his night attacks the Queen
but after Bishop takes obviously we
can't take back with the Queen so when
takes back with the pawn he's doomed and
the game concludes like this rook the d3
so he chomps that pawn rook queen well
queen rook get in a line here so they're
attacking this night so he just retreats
the night and now he's like I give up
all right he got he borrows night to
safety and everything was good so that
was in the Class B division here so now
now let's see a game this is why we all
here from the Missouri novice
Championship okay oh and one of these
guys this is actually board one of the
last round okay so we saw how the Class
B guys played so let's see how these
guys play here
all right here we go so white plays
efore white will be the hero maybe in
this game we'll see efore a five-night
attacks the pawn knight c6 Bishop the c4
okay so so I say it time and time again
even though hot two might not agree see
how mad she was with her when her
opponent played h6 she rambled on and on
and on about how bad h6 was but but she
didn't like it because she couldn't get
any attacks going so h 6 i'm still going
to say is acceptable here but Bishop c5
is obviously the best move followed by
Bishop e7 but when you play Knight f6
and you don't know what you're doing
you're going to get smashed okay so so
obviously the player playing black
didn't know about d5 so the only other
way to protect is e7 and it really
doesn't protect because after Knight
takes f7 gots what you're not going to
play Queen takes Knight anyway okay so
in the game you know yet he played work
to g8 alright so you see how Rick GA is
in the same line as this Bishop here
right so if you could just move the
night guess what die up the brook is
attacked so that's what he was thinking
and so he couldn't wait to take this
okay so Queen takes Bishop takes rook so
what would you guys play in this
position though which one yeah yeah you
could take first Queen takes e4 and
every blacks with the Queen guess what
will take this and then we'll be okay
okay but instead he doesn't do any of
that the this point is in a penny hahaha
yeah there's pawns in a pen and he knows
about oh we gotta attack 10 pieces but
if you can just take a pin peace through
it okay
so obviously why should not play Bishop
takes because Knight takes all right
instead he gets castled here okay so now
the right move is Knight takes bishop
but the last thing you want to do like
in that last game we saw is Queen takes
and whenever your queen and king or
lined up bad things are going to happen
right so so yeah yeah yeahs better get
divorce yeah get them separate keep them
separated yeah that's why the Kings and
the castle the Queen's out doing a thing
you know and that's how you should do it
I mean this is not good so so he attacks
the Queen all right so you could play f3
or you could just take what check would
you just take the check and then after
night takes we could get a pawn fork or
we could just take the bishop but he
goes for the pawn fork and and so now he
goes back and attacks the bishop again
so after takes takes this isn't doing so
well for uh for black here it gets
castled brings his Queen out Bishop
check but that's ok so now obviously you
got checked you know you should just
move move out of the check right we
don't want to go here right or else we'd
be putting our King and King and Queen
in the same line and rook f8 right so we
move to h1 but instead he plays d4 and
now after Knight takes he's threatening
a lot of discoveries here so so the
player plain white was obviously up a
bunch of material but now he's a falling
fast so Queen to d3 so what's a good
move for black in this position we see a
bunch of double checks right but just
because you can do a double check
doesn't necessarily mean that's the best
move
right even though it looks cool might
not be the best anybody got any ideas
and black can get back in this game
especially the way White's plane
excellent Mario yeah night take see to
check okay Bishop check and we'll go
back to h1 and then we can eat the rook
okay all right but unfortunately he does
none of that he plays rook to f8 I guess
he's preparing night to see to check
mate all right so so let's see if we can
find a boom for white to stop this
checkmate adjourn King h 1 0 King age 10
interesting you're good you're good
you're good because because nagda situ
is no longer check and obviously rook f1
is not check mate because I'm obviously
Queen takes rook good good adjourn good
so let's see what he plays it plays
Bishop e3 okay that was good too so now
Knight takes c2 and it's too late it's
too late for all that stuff okay so
Bishop takes Knight takes Bishop takes
Knight up and it's just going to get
over pretty quick here so obviously
August e is a great move for white here
Queen f5 check now you don't even have
to tell well you can just take it I mean
who wouldn't take it I mean you could
probably get checkmate but yes sir
that is just too good he's too good he's
too good I Grandmaster been fine go
found the right move to but you know
this is good to take all this stuff
penal check probably should have taken
the pawn but now I'll take the pawn but
check though and now everybody sees a
really cool mate here Knight takes b6
checkmate ok so now obviously you see
that's a game from the novice ok while
we're fighting the other game would like
to congratulate Kevin pile he's a
regular in this class and he he won the
under 1,200 press but we don't have a
game of his this is a maybe you guys
remember this guy from the SummerSlam
bash edition uh Michael Pugachev he's uh
he's pretty good player he uh he played
in the novice as well he didn't have a
quite the performance he wanted but
that's ok he's still young he's learning
so okay so Michael pugachev is playing
with the black pieces here ok so his
opponent David plays efore a 59 f 36
Saudi for and poo tkachev plays a check
which is not recommended so hopefully
you guys don't play that because now he
gets white essentially gets a free move
but his opponent puts his night there so
he's like okay i'll give you double
points so you got and now of course
Michael puka shell plays a very very bad
move here f6 never play up six remember
all right so attacks the night 97 now if
you really wanted to be ambitious here
you would play d6 shove it down his
throat but plays Bishop to e3 here and
and Pugachev wisely plays d6 before his
opponent could Bishop c4 so Bishop g4
pins the pins the night here so white
plays a 4
and so now he can check and it's
protected why he wanted to do that
unknown so Bishop d7 and now he's going
to get his forces over there so Rick v8
protects the pawn so Bishop takes check
wean takes and now adjourn you got to
move Bishop takes 87 why not right all
right so he obviously doesn't have time
to trap him because our work is attacked
so he's gonna he's got to try something
here instead of you know moving the rook
and then you know Queen takes all that
stuff he's going to try to get his own
attack going so let's check this out so
if Bishop takes Queen takes is there any
move we have to protect both of these I
see one but I don't know if it's any
good adjourned all right King e2 but
then we have to keep calculating here
okay 925 check right King III is is
black okay here yeah all right so so it
looks like he ran out of checks okay and
he looks like he's just down a rook
let's see what the computer has to say
about this yep it looks pretty good
White's up three points okay so so
that's what the player playing white
should have done to pugachov but instead
he freaks out here and he plays after
Queen to g4
he plays rook the g1 which allows check
King f1 let's check them again kingi one
check them again came to d1 so now he's
out of checks so rooked a and so now
Queen takes pawn cannot be played
because the rook hangs sorry retreats
the bishop safety plays b5 which I don't
really understand what's an obvious move
for white in this position Queen takes
pawn check yes yes Ponte yeah pawn takes
pawn you're right right because then you
play king and queen obviously in the
same line rook takes so that's that's a
it's not very good hope chest but okay
but he just he totally ignores the
threat and plays a bishop to d2 so now
he can protect the pawn here
oh wait in this position Queen yeah
right yeah check and then if oh if he's
placed these six here what we can just
just go back right yes a journey yes why
don't you get up here and the white is
just crushing excellent a journey okay
so so let's see so it's all right so he
Bishop d2 Queen c5 rook protects the
pawn and now he can take the pawn let's
check this out okay so he takes the pawn
here and now Queen to be seven attacks
the rook so now black offers the trade
so he could he could trade but he's
going for the checks rook be one
threatening so what'swhat's White's
threat when he's threatening our rookie
won in this position rook be seven right
that looks bad so Queen a6 offering the
trade but what else is he threatening
with Queen to a sex here they're the
rook the rook on f1 so let's see but
he's he wants to be check in here so
let's see if he's going to be fooled so
Queen to c7 check
boo-boo-boo-boo King up eight removes
the work down with chakia excellent yep
rook takes Queen takes check King up
seven Queen c7 check 90 and of course he
plays here now and would so he was so
busy with his attack he forgot Queen
takes check and up that's game he got
the last shot in and pugachev came
through and of one alright so we're
going to finish with a with a decent
game here from the Class B division Eric
tank chenko who's we've shown two losses
of him in this series so we're finally
going to give them some props here so
Eric tank chenko is playing the white
pieces Eric Tai took a clear second
undefeated alright so he starts out
efore his opponent Dallas place c5f
three you know so d5 is way too
ambitious in this opening here so you
can just take it a worst-case scenario
is you're going to get an isolated pawn
well best-case scenario worst-case is
what will happen so he took so now he
white is now up upon and when you're up
upon it's good because you can always
just give it back and then you're still
just tied you know so it's always take
free stuff Bishop b5 Bishop e7 so so
eric is up a pond he got castled so he's
playing pretty well h three stops any
kind of a pin here and so he likes h3 so
he decides to put a 3 here so now in
this position now which eric was here so
I could ask
okay so obviously why did black play
night to e4 yes right so do we want to
protect that pone the answer is yes I
mean why why do you play a three if
you're not going to play be four I mean
we might want to take this night before
we play be four but I just don't get it
all right so instead of defending his
pawn plays Knight to d2 and just lets it
happen and then of course what move do
you think white plays in this position
be four right yeah it would be a lot
cooler if you had a pawn on c5 buddy
alright so he got a temp oh wow okay I'd
rather have a pawn than a tempo alright
so now he takes the night pawn takes and
now night attacks the bishop and the
pawn so he protects the pawn and so
Knight takes pawn takes and you know
it's a roughly equal position here I
mean I might almost like black in this
position you got even amount of pawns
he's got one isolated pawn but he's got
all these nice Center pawns so I don't
know alright so Queen 2g for all right
he's getting the attack going here so
now we have a lot of different ways we
can protect this pun I personally like
'if I've but he chooses rook to f6
because I guess that stops Bishop to h6
all kinds of shenanigans so white gets
his pawn going so rook attacks the Queen
Queen to h3 each five so like in that
other game where black was putting his
rook up and down let's see if it works
out good for black are bad for black
because the rook was the hero in that
first game because he got the potential
pin on the e-file so let's see if this
rook maneuver is going to work out for
black
here so look a to e 1 so it's usually
never a good idea when you have these
two rooks too I mean you got to think
like do I want to work here maybe later
work here maybe later work here but by
playing this a rook to e1 you know this
work can't hop over so you're really
limiting yourself by playing that I
guess adjourn what do you think he wants
to get this f file open that's why he's
playing it well let's see if he ever
moves the f pawn alrighty five all right
so now so now we're going somewhere here
so Queen up five attacks the rook so how
do we want to defend this rook oh did we
blend just let them have it adjourn
what what's the answer you don't have it
anybody else so so obviously with Queen
up five it's a double attack right it's
attacking the rook and the polling you
got to be really careful how you protect
this rook here could almost protect it
yeah you can protect it with the Queen
you could protect it with the night you
could just move it so instead so so
let's see what the computer actually has
to say about this I'll be interested to
see what his thoughts are so so yeah
it's like it either rook up sticks or
queen to d6 and then you're going to
lose a pawn but you know it's better
than losing the alternative ok all right
so he decides to put rook the g4 so this
is a very awkward rook here ok and when
Brooks are deep in your territory
especially when its position is kind of
like jumbled or something it doesn't
have many spaces to go to bad things are
going to happen because if you look at
this rook now right what's the only
place it can go right now h4 right so
you'll every takes now where's the only
place this route can go or is that a
trick question nowhere so what do we do
the pieces that can't go anywhere g3
attack them right and should you just
give up here probably but he's going to
fight on and it's not going to be good
though but your might as well fight on
or eight pins the pawn
so now obviously we can play Queen takes
of h5 here but he doesn't want we could
play that but oh well gets his King out
of the way rook attacks the Queen Queen
back pawn up takes rook takes check
Knight takes Knight up obviously we know
what to do here pin it yeah yeah pin it
excellent and now yeah when you're up
you can just trade and you know he's got
nothing left it doesn't want play on
anymore because he's got no pieces ok so
that is that you guys want to see one
more puzzle before you leave alright
yeah alright here comes the puzzle if I
can find it you gotta hang tight here
though
you
you